the feeling i had
in being married was the safest feeling
i've ever had in my life i miss being
married adele isn't allowing divorce to
stop her from dreaming of walking down
the aisle again absolutely yeah
the 33 year old singer who split from
husband simon kaneki in 2019 sat down
with john mayer on siriusxm's hits one
to chat about her new album 30 but their
candid conversation turned to getting
hitched should i get married
oh yes you should get married
yes i am i think
i think it is a really incredible thing
marriage
um and i know that some people probably
think that i wouldn't think that you
know and like i gave up on it um
but
yes i think i think i think you should i
can't really say why but i'm definitely
open to marriage again i definitely am
adele even doubled down on all of that
and reflected on how being a wife made
her feel in being married was the safest
feeling i've ever had in my life
um and
you know sadly it didn't work out
um
but i you know i i miss being married so
now that it's clear adele is open to
marriage again you can't help but wonder
if powerhouse sports agent rich paul who
she's currently dating will be the lucky
man and i thought oh my god oh my god oh
god but one thing's for sure the hello
singer seems smitten here's what she
told oprah during her cbs concert
special adele one night only what was it
about him
that drew you to him i mean we all know
he's the super agent and yeah he's just
hilarious he's also hilarious oh he's so
funny okay back to 30 the album was
inspired by her divorce from kaneki
marking adele's first full-length record
in six years
john asked her how it feels to sing
lyrics that are no longer relevant to
her current life i'm so calm now at this
point in my life and i have made so much
progress from you know when it probably
would have come out last year to now
that maybe actually i wasn't ready for
it to come out last year
it might i might not have been in such a
sort of healthy place
um you know so that i'm actually now
grateful for
also for fans who are wondering if
you're going to be able to hear this
live
[Music]
baby
adele is saying no due to kova 19
concerns and large stadiums stadiums
being the venues she prefers you know
without standing spoiled it's easier
because it's right less shows get them
on one reach more people like you get to
stay in places because
you know to put down and then take down
up and put down the shows the sage
um but yeah i i don't think it's not
it doesn't sit right with me putting an
app putting an album out like this year
and then touring it in 2023
[Music]
adele's chat with john comes on the
heels of her hugely successful cbs
concert special with oprah is this the
divorce album
i think i'm divorcing myself on it where
she shared intimate details about how
her divorce made her face herself i
spent a lot of time on my own
really sitting in my feelings and not
keeping myself busy i used to always if
a feeling came up i'd distract myself or
i'd call a friend and be like i don't
want to go out what do you want to do
put a movie on whatever i would just sit
with it i would just eat it myself no
absolutely but i would just i would just
whenever i noticed how i was feeling i
would sit down and i'd sit in it in the
audience at adele show oprah's bestie
gail king who opened up to et about the
media mogul and superstar's dynamic
interview but just the two of them
together was really nice and it was very
intimate and very i wasn't there i
wasn't there i just heard from reliable
sources that it was really it was a very
special day i think for both of them
actually they had never met each other
before
i know i thought that too
thought that too kevin when she said
adele and i've never met i go what do
you mean you've never met they've never
met they've never met